Impartiality,
I think the question and those precisely
what it costs,
he knows exactly what it is.
Um,
it's,
what he's getting at is this notion that
the opposite is festering away in his
mind that the BBC is partial.
Uh,
first of all,
the BBC is not monolithic,
so therefore it is not partial that are
those people who work for,
to take one of you that are those people
who worked with you take another view.
Um,
but you asked you,
you've made it rather more personal than
that than you asked me about my
impartiality.
All I can tell you sir,
is that I've been doing this job on the
Today program for 27 years and I have
been accused,
but all of them
being unfair to all of them.
And I hope that continues because I
mean,
I know it's,
it's,
it's a rather crude and clumsy way of
measuring impartiality,
isn't it?
But,
uh,
but I reckon,
you know,
if,
um,
one moment you're being a attacked by
the Labor Party,
by the Conservative Party to other
poisoning the well,
the democratic debate,
which is what a certain Jonathan Econ
who subsequently went to jail,
but we'll put that to one side,
said it said about me and uh,
and then,
uh,
and then praise by the third party
simultaneously,
simultaneously for saving democracy on
behalf of the great relationship.
Then when the Labor party came to power,
all of a sudden you find that actually
as they said and left the BBC,
something must be done about the John
Humphrey's problem.
I mean,
you know,
that's the way it's,
it's politics for God's sake and you
should be able to enough and ugly enough
to know that.
And I would ask as for whether it's the
fault of the BBC or not.
And uh,
obviously you think it is the fault with
BBC,
whatever the full happens to be.
All I was held entirely serious here.
I put aside what the Today program does.
Some people like it,
some don't.
The BBC is ibelieve immensely important
to this country.
I struggled to imagine this country
without the BBC for all it.
Many,
many,
many folds.
I think it's a great civilizing.
It's tuition and I hope it survives.
Thank you.